[Musique]
voici ce qu'est la fête de la saint jean
a subi sur loire un mélange de
traditions locales qu'elles soient
culturelles ou gastronomique et un grand
marché à ciel ouvert consacré à la
chasse et à la pêche
aujourd'hui l'événement rassemble plus
de 20000 visiteurs mais aussi quelques
militants opposés à des activités ayant
pour finalité de tuer des animaux ou de
les exploiter à des fins commerciales
au niveau de la chasse on a à peu près
80 1% de personnes qui demandent une
réforme de la chasse et 69% dans le
sondage de 2010 9 qui est contre cette
activité donc ça représente quand même
une majorité de la population au niveau
des spectacles avec animaux c'est la
même chose on à 67% donc presque 7
français sur 10 qui demande
l'interdiction des spectacles avec
animaux sauvages dans les cirques et les
spectacles itinérants
si les résultats de ces sondages peuvent
être sujets à d'autres interprétations
il est indéniable que le sentiment anti
chasse s'est nettement développé les
organisateurs de la fête de la sant
gelade met mais insiste sur l'évolution
des pratiques des chasseurs et des
pêcheurs l'écologie se partagent la
biodiversité se partagent comme toute
activité aujourd'hui on va trouver des
chasseurs des pêcheurs on a également
des randonneurs on a des gens qui
pratiquent les sports équestres
c'est toute une partie de la ruralité
qui se retrouvent là après sûr c'est
pratique on a des gens qui ont un autre
courant de pensée il ya différentes
façons de faire façon de penser on est
en démocratie chacun est libre de
s'exprimer comme julia et c'est un
partage de l'espace
quant à la présence d'animaux sauvages
sur le site de l'événement cet éleveur
de rapaces le justifie par but
pédagogique
on porte un message de préservation de
la nature des espaces naturels
on travaille avec de la faune sauvage
captive nés en captivité pour protéger
la nature
on a en captivité avant tout un rôle de
conservateur d'espèces de faune sauvage
les positions des uns et des autres ne
se rapprocheront pas au cours du week
end les associations animalistes
promettent d'ailleurs d'intervenir
régulièrement pour susciter un débat
public et politique sur ces questions